à taille humaine les choses sont parfois
plus facile à appréhender comme
l'expliquent sept militaires ukrainienne
qui combat sur le front est coach coraux
c'est une tâche calme une fusée russe
cela fait longtemps qu'ils nous menacent
avec des armes de cette taille depuis
une semaine ils les utilisent beaucoup
un missile de courte portée très
destructeur quand il touche sa cible et
qui atteint aussi le moral et le contre
de telles armes nous ne pouvons répondre
qu avec de l'artillerie et des chars
malheureusement nous n'avons pas ce
matériel à disposition
sur la ligne de front tous pourtant
semble calme la confrontation directe
avec les russes n'a pas encore eu lieu
mais ces soldats zhu craignent ainsi
prépare en creusant toujours plus
profondément leur tranchée à l'appel et
quand ils quittent leur ligne défensive
la destruction n'est jamais très loin et
elle nous dit captant les russes n'ont
aucune dignité ils visent des civils pas
des gens qui sont dans l'armée dans
cette maison où vivait une vieille dame
elle est morte à tabarka la lassitude un
sentiment partagé par beaucoup de
soldats sucre aignan déployés sur le
front est
comme ce médecin de guerre dépourvu de
matériel de secours
dans ma trousse gd seringue jeunesse les
analgésiques
quelques cathéter des ciseaux du
sparadrap pour soigner les blessés c'est
tout ce que j'ai
mais ce sont surtout des armes beaucoup
d'armes qu'attendent soldats
d'ukrainiens aujourd'hui notamment des
blindés pour lutter d'égal à égal contre
les russes